let me try it out one of my recent
favorites which I devised to jangle the
nerves of neuroscientists who've been
going around saying that neuroscience
shows that we don't have free will I
think their reasons for saying that are
ill-considered and moreover that what
they're doing is apt to be mischievous
and doing some real harm
so I concocted a little thought
experiment a little intuition pump to
suggest that so this is the the case of
the nefarious neurosurgeon who treats a
patient who has obsessive-compulsive
disorder by inserting a little microchip
in his brain which controls the OCD the
obsessive compulsive disorder now there
is such a chip it's been developed in in
the Netherlands and it works really
quite well that's science fact but now
here comes science fiction so the
neurosurgeon after she's operated on the
guy sewed them all up so okay your your
OCD is under control now you'll be happy
to learn but moreover our team here will
be monitoring you 24/7 and we're going
to be controlling everything you do from
now on you'll think you have free will
you think you'll think you're making
your own decisions but really you won't
have free will at all free will is an
illusion that we will maintain while
controlling you good bye have a nice
life sends about the door well he
believes her she had a shiny lab and you
know lots of degrees diplomas and all
that so what does he do well he thinking
he doesn't have free will anymore he
gets a little self indulgent a little
bit aggressive he little negligent and
how he decides what to do and pretty
soon you know by by indulging some of
his worst features he's got himself in
trouble with the law and he's arrested
and he's put on trial and at the trial
he says but your honor
I don't have free will I'm under the
control of the team at the
neurosurgery clinic I say what's this
and they called a neurosurgeon to the
stand
I said did you tell this man that you
were controlling his every move he
didn't have free will
he's just young I did yeah but I was
just messing with his head that was just
a joke I didn't think he'd believe me
now right there I think we can stop take
a deep breath and say well she did
something really bad that was that was
really truly harm damn and in fact her
little joke telling that actually
accomplished non-surgically pretty much
what she claimed accomplishes
accomplished surgically she disabled him
by telling him he didn't have free will
she pretty much turned his freewill off
and turned him into a morally
incompetent person now if we agree that
she did a bad thing if nobody recommends
people play jokes like this what are we
to say about the neuroscientists who are
telling the public every day we've shown
in our neuroscience labs that nobody has
free will I think if the neuroscientists
recognize that what my imaginary
neurosurgeon did was irresponsible they
should think saris seriously about
whether it's irresponsible of them to
make these claims about free will and
it's not just a fantasy Vossen schooler
in an important paper which has been
replicated in several different ways set
up an experiment really to test this
with college students who were given two
texts to read one was a text they were
both from Francis Crick's book the
astonishing hypothesis and one was not
about free will
I'm the other was about free will and
basically it said free will is an
illusion all your decisions are actually
determined by causes that that
neuroscience is investigating you don't
have free will that's just an illusion
all right so that we have two groups the
group that read that passage in the
group that read another passage from
that book of the same length after
they've read the passage they are given
a puzzle to solve where they can earn
some money by solving it and the
experimenters cleverly made the puzzle
slightly defective so there was a way of
cheating on the puzzle that was oops
inadvertently revealed to the subjects
and guess what the subjects who read the
passage where Crick says free will is an
illusion cheated at a much higher rate
than the other ones in other words just
reading that passage did have the effect
of making them less concerned about the
implications of their action and just
they became as it were negligent or
worse in their own decision-making I
think that's an important and sobering
thought